BURLINGTON.
NO REASON THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY
SHOULD HAVE ALL OF THE BENEFIT
OF DIVERSITY.
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON HAS WATCHED
ALL OF THIS HAPPEN.
HE IS THE SENIOR AT THE HOOVER
INSTITUTION AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
PAIRED SO YOU SEE THIS MASSIVE
DISCONNECT WHERE YOU HAVE THIS
PARTY THAT IS OPENLY AND VERY
AGGRESSIVELY WHITE AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT ITS
LEADERS INCLUDING LEADERS OF
COLOR LIKE THE OBAMA'S LIVE IN
ALL WHITE NEIGHBORHOODS, HOW
LONG CAN THAT CONTINUE I WONDER?
>> I DON'T THINK IT IS
SUSTAINABLE.
WHAT IS NEW ABOUT THE BORDER,
TUCKER IS IT DOES NOT EXIST.
THEY BLEW IT UP.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
FEDERAL LAW, IT IS AN
INSURRECTION TO USE THAT ACT.
YOU ASK YOURSELF WHY ARE
3 MILLION PEOPLE GOING TO COME
IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
AND THE ANSWER IS IT IS THE
MANIFESTATION OF THIS BICOASTAL
ELITE TO THAT IS NEVER SUBJECT
TO THE CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR OWN
IDEOLOGY.
THEY WANT VACCINATION, ANYBODY
THAT IS NOT VAXXED IN THE
MILITARY COME OUT, ANYBODY IN
THE FEDERAL WORKFORCE, OUT.
3 MILLION PEOPLE UNTESTED,
UNVACCINATED, NO PROBLEM
WHATSOEVER.
LAWS ARE CALCIFIED, THEY DON'T
WORK.
BUT I HAVE TO HAVE A BIG WALLET
MALIBU ET CETERA, AND THEN
SCHOOLS, WE HAVE TO HAVE A
DIVERSE SCHOOL, BUT MY KIDS WILL
BE AT A PRIVATE ACADEMY.
AND I LOVE DIVERSITY, BUT ONLY
AS AN EMPLOYER THAT HIRES CHEAP
LABOR.
SO THIS ISN'T NIHILISM.
AND IT REALLY BEGS THE QUESTION,
WHERE ARE THEY DOING THIS?
IT'S ALMOST A PSYCHOLOGICAL
PROJECTION SO THAT THEY KNOW
THAT THEY ARE GUILTY THAT THEY
LIVE APART TIED SEGREGATED
EXISTENCE AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
CHANGE IT, BUT THEY THINK BY
PERFORMANCE ART AND VIRTUE
ESTATE PLANNING THE ABSTRACT, I
AM FOR DIVERSITY AND OPEN
BORDERS, THAN THAT SQUARES THE
CIRCLE OF THEIR OWN PRIVILEGE
AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY IS ON
TO THEM.
THERE IS ONLY ONE I THINK
OPTIMISTIC CHANCE WHICH IS THE
HISPANIC VOTE AND ESPECIALLY THE
MEXICAN-AMERICAN BOATS, THE
COMMUNITY MOST IMPACTED BY
FLOODED SOCIAL SERVICES AND
SCHOOLS THAT CAN'T HANDLE THIS
INFLUX AND THE INCREASE IN
CRIME.
IF THEY VOTE 50/50 FOR A
CONSERVATIVE CANDIDATES, BELIEVE
ME, YOU WILL HEAR THE 1992, 1996
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION RHETORIC
OF NANCY PELOSI, CHUCK SCHUMER,
THE CLINTONS ON HOW WE HAVE TO
HAVE LEGAL ONLY IMMIGRATION,
BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT WANT TO
IMPORT PEOPLE WHO ARE INNATELY
CONSERVATIVE.
AND JUST TO FINISH COMING YOU
MENTION ALL OF THESE
HYPOTHETICALS THAT WERE REALLY
INTERESTING, I COULD ADD ONE
MODEST ONE, AS WE SPEAK, TUCKER,
OUR MAJOR UNIVERSITIES ARE IN
RECESS, THERE IS ABOUT 4 MILLION
DORMS NATIONWIDE, RIGHT NOW THAT
ARE EMPTY.
AND WE HEAR ALL OF THIS VIRTUAL
SIGNET BILLING TO LIMIT
SIGNALING, THESE ARE THE IDEAL
PLACES, THEY HAVE OPEN HOUSING,
YOU COULD BRING IN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND FLY THEM IN, THEY
ARE MEDICAL SCHOOLS OFFERING
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE, THEY HAVE
LEGAL LAW SCHOOLS, THEY COULD
OFFER A LEGAL, THEY HAVE INTERNS
THAT CAN HELP WITH IMMERSION
ENGLISH PROGRAMS, THIS WILL BE
THE SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM COME
THE UNIVERSITIES COULD STEP UP
AND SAY WE WANT TO REIFY OUR
RHETORIC WITH CONCRETE ACTION,
WE HAD THE FACILITIES, BRING
THEM IN.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A WONDERFUL,
NOBLE AND MORAL EXPERIENCE IF
OUR COLLEAGUES EXCEPT THAT.
>> Tucker: LET THEM REPOPULATE
THE UNIVERSITY.
TURN THEM OVER AND LET THEM
STAY.
THEY CAN PAY FOR IT.
I COULD NOT AGREE MORE.
I LOVE THAT IDEA.
THAN